premier casting du jour c'est bernard
montiel je suis très heureux parce que
c'est les plus populaires des animateurs
ce sont les gens de la météo les plus
populaires sur les rails alors comment
colisée devant ainsi pour expliquer hier
le fonds le fonds vert est là et on va
donc remettre une carte pour bernard
mais pour compiler un petit peu la chose
ah bon je vais abbas il va forcément je
vais vous donner trois mots qu'il faudra
placer dans votre météo d'accord de
allez je vais interpeller m 2 vous allez
me placer bruine bruine et crachats et
crachin si vous à ce que pareil
non c'est pas pareil d'accord parce
qu'il peut brunet ekra chine est bon
alors vous savez qu'il ya un fond vert
mais là il ya un écran que vous êtes
devant et ben à les y attendait bernard
montiel première voilà chers amis pour
ça je suis très heureux de vous
accueillir pour cette météo oui
évidemment voulez savoir quel temps il
fera demain
eh bien on va en parler maintenant alors
regardez déjà là ça commence c'est un
des trucs et lamotte a cessé la mer ça
de la bruine évidemment ces frais senti
ça commence
c'est le matin ça va bien se passer là
au plus tôt là c'est carrément du
crachin du crachin sur le pays
lillois les hauts de france c'est bien
regrettable et là-haut quoi la haute
amer c'est pas fini et là on ne plie pas
c'est merveilleux pays bas où il fait
toujours beau quoi qu'ils aient un petit
nuage mais vous inquiétez pas ça passe
et paris il fait très beau à paris il
fait très beau à paris porte de cet
effet combien par ses bienfaits qui
convient à paris il fait bon là ça fait
loin pour moi c'est que j'ai 18 ou un
truc en angola et au calme et à la fin
je vois pas
vous êtes consternant mais je vois pas
moins de l'abattage me rapprocher alors
dans l'est strasbourg c ou strasbourg
strasbourg c'est la découvert ses
couverts c'est la merde mais strasbourg
on aime beaucoup ses magnifiques
strasbourg est là et la cathédrale est
un peu plus bas dans le sud là où j'ai
l'habitude d'aller aussi je suis devant
regardez-la la voilà c'est magnifique la
voilà voilà
lassé nuageux mais ça va vite ça s'est
passé alors la tramontane va on va on va
s'arrêter de là les amis mais ce que
c'est absolument nulle je lance un petit
sondage sur twitter vous nous dites quel
est votre miss météo préfère donc il y
avait bernard montiel en numéro 1 voilà
voilà c'était franchement je vous le dis
voyez la barre des 20 des jeunes en
début dé meteonews et comme vous jamais
j'avais alors ce que t'es mignon c'est
que nous avons maintenant ne connaît pas
les causes qui s'est fait une antisèche
je vais vous montrer qu'il est juste là
c'est pas bien de faire ça moi je moi je
dis tout le netto alors je vais vous
donner deux mois à placer alors vous que
vous êtes est extrêmement bas sera il
faudra passer le mot dépression d'accord
est passé le mot épisodes cévenols
déjà faut savoir que c'est qu'un débris
7,9 eason un cévenol
voilà alors c'est un orage dans le sud
de la france voilà un épisode celle de
la wii cévenol dans les cévennes dans
les cévennes le mais quand vous parlez
alors c'est bon très bien 3,2 à la
dépression parce qu'elle est grosse
dépression sur le pays
mais c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
puisque un moment donné vous aviez hier
et demain matin c'était plutôt qu'à la
la je suis dans la mer alors regardez
moi faire un petit point rapidement
demain matin donc polaire il fera à 9
degrés à paris mais non c'est dans lola
mais qu'est ce que tu me fais là cette
enveloppe est alors comment je fais pour
moi c'était de faire aimer chez moi même
nous aider à paris strasbourg il fauit
degré coeur demain après midi
regardez comme vous mettiez regarder il
faut arrêter de regarder
voilà on se fait qu'on se recule voilà à
ce point mais voilà mais oui mais moi je
vais vous dire voilà chez le docteur
nationale voilà ouais bah là où paris il
fera 9 degrés n'ont pas semblé voilà
l'arrivée la 9° paris 9 2 il faut pas
trop bouger il faut avoir l'habitude des
15 degrés l'après midi donc ça c'est
vraiment formidable
je n'ose pas vous dire où se trouve
marseille à droite droite voilà
marseille à 17 degrés et puis on pourra
aller en corse où il fera 22 degrés
parade c'est mieux demain après-midi ce
qui est quand même pas mal c'est hp oui
oui vous êtes sérieux attention petite
dépression c'était demain matin et
l'après-midi tout va se dégager on va se
retrouver dans une canicule assez
extraordinaire l'épisode symbole on va
en parler puisque vivement à ces bons à
6 degrés à l'est bravo c'est pas mal
c'est donc allez c'est drôle non plus ne
verront pas certain donc des gamins des
gosses et numéro deux pour la miss météo
exceptionnelle donc pour l'instant les
garçons n'ont pas été spécialement
brillé au mas menti favoris déjà acquise
alors entre pas bon et payent pas bon
j'ai du mal à choisir d'accord mais je
pense qu avez-vous géraldine on va aussi
un casse ça devrait mieux se passer
alors deux petits mois placé
cumulonimbus oui et giboulées d'accord
ok je vous laisse
ok mais prête en easy la météo et à vous
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir je suis
très heureuse de vous accueillir pour
découvrir le temps que nous allons avoir
aujourd'hui
alors avant une carte de francs un petit
peu divisé en deux nous avons une moitié
nord plutôt ensoleillé nous aurons
quelques cumulonimbus on entrait
maritime au niveau de la bretagne
l'ouest de la france bravo biarritz
toulouse mon pays d'origine bien sûr que
j'adore alors ce sera un tout petit peu
plus orageux avec évidemment comme il
est de saison en mars des giboulées
mais rien de grave ouais ouais ouais ce
de la france la normandie avec un très
grand soleil plutôt radieux des
températures agréables
il fera frais 1 le matin couvrez vous
bien embêté vaut un petit gilet mais
l'ex n 1 entre le 12 dans le 13 degrés
au niveau de l'est de la france région
paca encore des quelques giboulées un
surtout surtout dans la région paca rien
rien de spectaculaire l'est de la france
ce sera des petites entrées maritimes
même si elles sont de très très loin
parce qu'elle a un très bon été dans les
gros c'est un nouveau concept
d'ingénieurs voilà globalement voilà le
printemps se profile alors là je vous
dis franchement alors elles ont peu à
peu des rois mais alors vraiment alors
là
c'était franchement on fermait les yeux
on s'y croit fait mon côté evelyne
dhéliat des gens qui nous ont regardés
des gens de chaînes je pense que vous
avez un avenir dans la météo s faire
bien à 50 ans il parcourt une nouvelle
carrière niveau des miss météo sont
regardés qui est là pour faire la météo
alors guillaume genton d'abord choisi
celui-là
merci la tenue voulait pas mal pas mal
ou non plus pas mal je n'aurais pas
acheté mais c'est pas mal
alors le principe vous le connaissez
vous déjà une petite vidéo c'est un
casting très sérieux pour apprécier l
impression mais justement vous allez
devoir placer comme mot dépression
dépression dépression l'échangé des
pressions et et et pression
atmosphérique dépression et pression
préféré ça va de pair ok on est passé
par 6-3 2-1 top
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans la météo
on va parler des pressions on va parler
pression atmosphérique et on va bien sûr
par les vêtements puisque vous allez
enfin savoir comment vous alliez demain
je sais que comme moi vous aimez la mode
un petit coup d'oeil sur les
températures demain donc une france
vraiment divisé en 2 1 comme l'a dit
géraldine tout à l'heure aux rousses et
ensoleillé vous allez pouvoir sortir vos
plus beaux tee shirt ou vos plumes au
veston d'un comme benjamin castaldi pas
mention dans le sud de la france ça va
se refroidir avec des températures aux
alentours de 10 degrés on opte pour une
petite laine un petit blouson en cuir un
petit manteau mi saison
est ce que c'est vrai qu'il faut se
méfier de ces températures ces bâtards
y'a plus de saison ma bonne dame tenue
demain je note cependant à strasbourg
une
une intégration cet arrêt à 14 degrés
c'est ma ville de coeur vous allez
pouvoir sortir vos marcel vaut mieux
être de strasbourg julien strasbourg et
j'embrasse ma saucisse est également
voilà d'où mon physique non savoir vous
habiller comme vous le voulez à
strasbourg un des petits marcel des
petits t-shirt donc n'hésitez pas à vous
habiller comme vous le souhaitez et puis
en bretagne plein soleil en tout cas
habillez-vous comme cool et n'oubliez
pas sortez couverts surtout merci si le
bassin méditerranéen
là où passé aux vacances du mois saint
tropez tout va bien c'est décevant mais
n'ont cessé sans rester mariés dans le
sud dans le sud voilà on voit que c'est
vrai et c'est nul je ici et si c'est
plus ensoleillés donc va falloir faire
attention
prévoyez un petit blouson misère quand
même pas mal non pas mal bon ben on peut
le dire quand même est-ce que vraiment
déconné voilà d'abord nous avons madame
marie dubosc patrick thaler le le cas
sinon je vais vous mettre comme mots
vous allez mettre condensation et
précipitation ok isabelle c'est tabou la
caméra est là
alors comme j'ai le bassin extrêmement
parisien je vais commencer par la région
parisienne fin la région parisienne -
elle est plutôt par la bbc à londres
excusez moi mais bon c'est comme ça
attendons les pressions taisez vous
contrairement à ma région de coeur qui
est l'est et alors là dans l'est il ya
ceux ci l'a par exemple ça va être moins
bien mais quand même c'est pas mal du
tout alors la bretagne je m'en fiche
parce que je ne connais personne en
breton maire de dagne c'est pas mal
c'est la mer ça c'est pas du tout la
bretagne du tout par exemple dans le
sud-ouest petits messages codés pour mon
front et en espagne manu non non et oui
c'est bien
manu amuse-toi pas trop chaudement fois
là il va y avoir une
quand m il ya pas mal de condensation
dans ce coin-là free alors là quand même
quand même de regarder ou jouer à les
loups alors prochain alors là c'est sans
doute dans l'est vers le lac léman voyez
vous devriez venir avec moi parce que ça
va être pas mal dit merci
alors je peux vous dire quelque chose
c'était pas terrible non faussée pas
écouté non parce que c'est un c'est un
beau métier reste miss météo c'est un
média prendre avec considération c'est
pour ça doit être très bien isabelle
adoré faire ça là bas tant mieux je suis
content d'être ému lui plaisait et aulas
normalement on aime concurrents puisque
pour l'instant c'est géraldine que j'ai
préféré ensuite il y à guillaume puy
puis bernard et enfin évidemment
rastaman à savoir des connaître les
causes qui vous a pas du tout convaincu
mais comment comment peut-il et
convaincant quand tu vois la météo je ne
sais pas alors comment entendez-vous
nathalie j'ai dit alors déjà au niveau
look
on est quand même loin de la miss météo
quand même de grandes qualités ambiance
ibiza toujours pas toujours pas
recommencé au soleil alors je vais pas
être trop trop dur avec vous allez me
placer comme mot été caniculaire et
et tramontane trois deux un casting de
nathalie marquay-pernaut s'élargit
bonsoir donc déjà je n'ai pas besoin de
ça merci et voilà j'ai fait avec les
mains ce sera beaucoup plus facile
donc il m'a demandé tramontane qui vont
monter sur excusez moi de l'autre sens
côté
alors la tramontane pousse et ça descend
voilà bien sûr n'ont eu les vosges aussi
gagné tout est ensuite une canne et
d'une queue du lean canicule
extraordinaire parce que nous avons
vraiment où tous là dans le sud pas loin
de l'espagne si là-bas ou alors on fait
métaux pour la france et à la frontière
n'est pas loin donc voilà pour ce qu'ils
peuvent sortir c'est vrai qu'on est en
confinement mais on peut rêver ça fait
du bien de rêver donc il faut rêver donc
voila mais par contre on santos entre
eybens et comme d'habitude ici là et là
on a une chance puni parce que
exceptionnellement au centre nous avons
du soleil et we hate magnifique soleil
sur dans le nord nous avons les nuages
comme d'habitude un monsieur benjamin
castaldi et ça descend aussi jusqu'à la
bretagne est malheureusement mais
surtout ce que j'ai à vous dire très
bien quelle autre ville de coeur moi
c'est l'alsace à l'aja alors là that we
la samba la place est allée un peu mais
vous n'y mettez plutôt les pardonner
installez-vous kelly c'est la suivante
pour le bas c'est le casting météo n'y a
pas la carte
elle est là la carte maîtresse à
l'antenne mais aussi sur ces vies tout
ça dans le 6ème et casta les douches
vous êtes là pour relever le défi de
miss météo pour l'instant c'est
géraldine qui est très largement en tête
suivi de guillaume haka après bon après
aprilia bernard et après peloton de tête
et isa et nathalie est toujours à sera
man qui est d'ailleurs qui est dernier
vous vous êtes déjà physiquement des
dates parfaitement un personnage de la
route ou alors et puis surtout le
sourire alors la mode caméra et l'a1
vous allez donc classer le mot bruines
ou crachins que vous préférez vous les
donne à partir sur crash un crachin
allocation trois deux un casting miss
météo tous et bienvenue dans la météo de
kelly donc je suis ravi de vous
retrouver ce soir vous présentez votre
météo que vous allez subir ou pas pour
demain nous voici donc je vous présente
ici la météo
donc vous avez pour la bretagne
ici vous êtes comme dans l'atlantique
vous n'êtes pas loin de new york vous
avez pour la bretagne ici très bien le
soleil parce que méfiez vous des
apparences généralement bretagne il fait
beau contrairement à ce qu'on peut dire
vous avez ici également vers marseille
le beau temps comme d'habitude vous
pouvez vous en douter marseille c'est
quand même la belle vie le soleil et le
pastis et je suis également son
agglomération
à consommer avec modération bien sûr et
je suis très contente de vous apprendre
aussi qu'à lille malgré les apparences
j'avais mon père m guterres a lille
malgré les apparences vous avez
également du beau temps alors selon ce
qu on dit généralement en bretagne a
beaucoup d'eux crash alors c'est pas
vrai c'est une légende c'est une légende
évidemment parce que en ce moment il
fait quand même plutôt bons donc vous
allez voir que dans le massif central
c'est plutôt moi qui comptais boulot
c'est plutôt nuageux mais je vous
préconise d'utiliser bien sûr vos
parapluies et vos petites boîtes
sur ce je vous vois surtout demande
juste d'être heureux dans vos vies de
profiter de chaque instant avec vos
proches tant que vous pouvez et
n'oubliez pas de chez vous j'ai écouté
pas mal j'ai bien aimé votre météo
vraiment c'est vrai et grand plaisir non
franchement ça m'a touchée ça m'a fait
plaisir alors nous sommes donc donc
parce que la fin de ce casting de miss
météo a pour l'instant je vous le dis
vous avez adoré géraldine très très loin
devant et vous allez adorer qu'il est
normal de beaux sourires de très belles
femmes et guy idiots qui d'ailleurs ne
venez pas si loin mais guillaume on
concède on sait qu'il est bel et bon
alors là je suis pas certain que la
personne qui arrive maintenant sept 7
personnes ici présentes soit le meilleur
challengeur impôts
parce qu'apple gilles oui je vous répète
que vous dites souvent cyril calme ce
météo c'est pas un combat c'est pas une
joute verbale il ya personne a engueulé
on ait la peau on est là pour donner
dame était aux gens avec le sourire et
la gentillesse et bien sûr alors vous
allez me placer un mot oui anticyclone
en va autrement
anticyclone de fred casting gilles
verdez miss météo 2021 c'est parti chers
amis attention parce que cet anticyclone
là c'est lui qui vient d'angleterre
regardez ils se déplacent et il va
envahir la normandie il va envahir la
normandie et puis aussi lille où
l'anticyclone va régner en revanche à
strasbourg à strasbourg quelques petits
nuages alors qu'à disions il fait beau
toujours à dijon où il ya la moutarde
carton matin vers nice à l'aînée souad
les adore nice marseille quelques petits
nuages du mistral et de la tramontane
attention et que sur les pyrénées nous
avons des pluies tout petit plus
quelques gouttes
terminons si vous le voulez bien par le
centre de la france souvent oublié nos
belles villes du centre à orléans à
orléans la ville de la belle jeanne
d'arc et bien orléans capifrance soleil
magnifique
ab franchement là je dis bravo clair
précis argumenté en jeu comme si vous
n'êtes pas mauvais en géographie pas
mauvaise mais fait des longues
savez-vous qu'une étude d'ailleurs j'ai
fait des tas d'histoires et trois ans de
doctorat et licence de géographie
notamment à oui très bien là bas ça ne
se voit pas toujours mais là ça sourit
si tu sais tu très honnête
voilà le pire c'est que vous semblez
surpris après vous allez prendre ma
place et je chaîne météo
pour moi ce que j'ai appris à baba est
faux mais je mesure à mon grand casting
de la météo et anti jeunes et un petit
jeune qui a envie de réussir il est là
c'est bon merci pour la première fois la
météo et c'est vrai avec un jour après
c'est allé vite et il m'a très bien
alors les amis pour l'instant toujours
en tête j'ai râlé mais gilles vous avez
beaucoup plus à aller j'en ai mais
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir une météo avec le coeur ce soir
nous avons bien sûr du soleil sur la sur
la france une partie de la france avec
notamment du soleil sur la bretagne ici
avec eux bref quelle belle ville brest à
hawaï bresse
alors tout le pourtour de l'atlantique
est assez ensoleillé on remarque que
l'anticyclone des açores remonte les
amants et pousse les nuages pousse des
nuages vers évidemment vers vers le
sud-ouest évidemment le sud-ouest ici
avec biarritz biarritz toulouse et
d'avoir si bien sûr la wiener monde est
normal et pignons et on va remonter tout
ça ici avec la région paca marseille
marseille et la très belle ville de lys
en eas qu'on embrasse qu on a dormi ces
deux là où il fait toujours beau il ya
souvent un très beau soleil
ceci étant je tiens à attirer votre
attention sur une alerte une alerte
chaleur il fera une charade à
monumentale sur la france du côté de
paris à l'appareil voilà paris 6 paris
là avec une tentative à monte monte
monte et on connaît l'origine de cette
race est effectivement l'émanation de la
chaleur qui vient du plateau de thé pmp
et donc pour le résultat du casting de
miss météo grande gagnante est bien
c'est géraldine deuxième votre serviteur
3e 3e kelly quatrième globe dont on le
reste ça n'a pas grand intérêt